صوت الرصاص يصدح في مختلف ارجاء السودان
فالمعارك اشتدت خلال اليوم الثاني من
المواجهه العسكريه بين الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريع من بين ابرز النقاط
الساخنه لليوم الثاني مقر القياده العامه
للجيش الواقعي شمال العاصمه الخرطوم
فالاقتتال لم يتوقف في محيط مركز القياده
وسط تداول اخبار عن استخدام اسلحه ثقيله
وغير بعيد عن مركز القياده تواصلت
اشتباكات في مطار الخرطوم مسببه خسائر
فادحه هذا ما نقرته صور بالاقمار
الاصطناعيه والتي اظهرت حجم الضمائر الذي
لحق بالمبنى الرئيسي للمطار والجسور
المؤديه اليه فضلا عن الحريق الذي نشب في
مستودعات الوقود اثار الدمار بدجليه بعد
يومين فقط من القتال كما هو الحال بالنسبه
لمبنى القياده العامه للقوات البريه والذي
تضرر بشكل واضح في شمال البلاد وتحديدا في
مدينه مروي فان الاوضاع شهدت هدوءا حذرا
باعلان السوداني سيطرته على القاعده
العسكريه بعد انسحاب قوات الدعم السريع
القتال امتد الى عده اجزاء اخرى من
السودان من بينها بورت سودان وسواكن والتي
شهدت نشوب اشتباكات بين الجانبين وسط
انتشار كثيف للاليات العسكريه وبرغم
موافقه الطرفين على مقترح الامم المتحده
بفتح مسارات امنه للحالات الانسانيه لمده
ثلاث ساعات فقط فان ذلك لم يحصل بل استمرت
الاشتباكات في اكثر من موقع في العاصمه
وخارجها وسام الذهبي العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات